you know um it's time maybe it's time to
it's time to just it's time they've just
wake up I think you know we rolling out
this virus bed back out Aneta into the
world you know it's time to get your
legs going see if you still got him
you know we met when I was young we had
a man bus this man big Gilroy they
called him and he had what they call a
little first snake on him that FS hit
her and what it was was everybody
thought oh he gots a snake that has a
hair malfunction
you know if a snake that's covered in
hair but it was a squirrel that had lost
its legs in an accident some type of
accident and all four of its legs had
been decapitated like you know I don't
even know print there's something
shoveling I don't know I guess it could
have been like an automobile accident or
something myth or somehow but anyway and
if you looked at it it looked like a
damn first night so it was just you know
everything just no matter really a
perception it's how you look at it you
know we could have been sad when
gillware would bring it we could have
got out the Kleenex and the damn you
know a little you know something sad a
little sad you know a little drawing a
picture of the Grim Reaper done
something like that and said aw what's
so sad you know he got to know legged
you know tree marsupial out here
squirrel but instead everybody said oh
wow look at this he got that beautiful
person
he got that footless little little
critter hitter again
[Music]
celebrate
I'm preparing to turn
have some fun
we celebrate
you got to celebrate them you know you
can have that little you could have that
little I see you squirrel and look at it
that's on the sad route and travel
through the freakin tear Creek or you
could ride that wave of just excitement
and say I have dang gilroy guts a first
snake good to be here good to be here
hope you are well I hope I'm well that's
always a concern it is may it is 2020
and we are traveling in the time at the
speed we've always gone into it at so we
are traveling exactly the same speed
forward into time and that's where we
are oh you had a nice weekend and I hope
you had that nice Mother's Day you know
the the power of a mother just that
ability to create something in your body
I mean that's really that's magic
there's no and you know I know Siegfried
died or whatever you know and I know he
died and him and his friend or husband
they you know they were lovers or
something when one of them died right
but but that's artificial you know that
beautiful gay bad boy he couldn't pull
another person out of his body I mean
not that he had formed he could I'm sure
he'd done some stuff but you know uh a
mother's got that ultimate that Rubik's
Cube inside of them that little
formulator that Aubrey
and they'll roll out a baby like that
that's God's Yahtzee right there i'ma
roll a baby you feel me and I'm gonna
use your mother to do it I hope you had
a nice Mother's Day and happy Mother's
Day to all those single moms out there
and and just know that you are loved I
uh what did I get to do I got to go too
why didn't I didn't do too much man I
went for a run worked out cook me up a
little burger meat you know the doctor
has me on a grass-fed meat now so the
animals that I'm eating if he had been
eating grass so it's you know we're all
doing our part I guess and you know I
like to get me a burger
made out of beef meat I'll do beef meat
and I'll get that burger that burger
patty and and I like to cut it up put it
in a bowl cut me a nice toe mod in there
one of them Creole tomatoes cut that bad
[ __ ] up like I like I just met that MFR
in a Japanese alley and it owes me money
dawg I was a slice that bad [ __ ] up
and then I get me a that I walk taught
me that Spanish avocado and I'll slice
that bad cat up you know I'll
straight-up get into that sucker put
that in a bowl dice it up throw a little
avocado oil on it a little salt a little
sea salt or to even just land salt I use
the original [ __ ] bro
that basic ass land salt brother kind of
[ __ ] used to get at school and I throw
that in that bowl and get that tasty
that tasty little that beef patty salad
and then I had a friend growing up his
mother was named patty and that always
blew my mind you know to name your child
after a dam cut of cooked meat or shaped
meat how you gonna name your child after
a meat shape notice patty
oh hey patty behave patty I'm gonna put
you on the grill Oh patty and then for
fun you take a piece of cheese and just
put it on Patty's head oh look what we
did to patty oh that's cute you know
doing little children can be very you
know little you know there's something
unique about them um when my niece was
born you know my sister had it my sister
had you know father or parent get birth
to my niece she gave birth to had a
little beautiful little damn crotch
nugget and and we'd never had a baby
before in our family nobody had ever had
a baby hell no one had he ever even
walked in on anybody else masturbating
or anything in our house and I remember
we went to Chili's and Chili's if you're
not familiar with it it's they kind of
act like it's Mexican but it's like just
everybody from your high school started
a restaurant and and basically Chili's
had these chips they had this you get
the order of chips and salsa brah and
they hit you with the bowl of chips this
basket it looked like half of a little
like a Mexican hat it almost looked like
a little yarmulke for like a little
Mexican [ __ ] or little person my bad
and that thing would be full of chips or
jeeps and you get the little dish of
Sal's a bra and
and if you're like me you order your own
salza for your half at a table because I
don't like it you got four people there
they bring one thing of keeps and one
thing as alza' no bring 2,000
bring 2,000 cuz I'm gonna take I'm gonna
put one in my area you know I'm fine
sharing one but I'm not like there's two
if there's four people you need two
Salle's man I just hate that [ __ ] they
just make it they want to create tension
right off the bat but I remember my my
little niece you know we'd never had a
baby in our family and she was real
little I mean I mean real little I mean
a [ __ ] fat squirrel could have given
birth to this baby and we put her in the
little chip dish we took the chips out
and put her in there and we put the
chips on top of her and we kind of just
ate the chips and you know and she was
you know kind of asleep or just too
young to open her eyes but just kind of
a beautiful family moment that we had
you know years ago when my niece was
first born at the Chili's what's going
on not too much I'm happy to be here
hope you guys have had a nice weekend
what else oh I went over to David
Spade's and I watched the fights the
fistfights maybe UFC and we're lucky we
got dust in the diamond Poirier he's
gonna be on in a little while we're
gonna zoom with him and talk with him
you know he's right there in the thick
of all of that and just excited to get
to chat with my buddy anyway and see how
he's doing and and a man those fights
were exciting you know those fights were
really really exciting a
it was interesting now if you go to
david spade's home and I am home
dropping I'm home dropping I'll be
honest with you and we went and and they
had I mean he has you know they got a
lot of different you know rich looking
stuff in there he's got one of those
houses I've got a couple different
living rooms in it like one of them
looks like a lobby of like a UH like at
the bank you know he got some one area
like you could do a chase or a Wells
Fargo the business area and then they
got a you know he's got a button you
press and the damn curtains come down I
mean it's just I mean hell it would be
it's the kind of place I wouldn't even
masturbate in this place it's nice you
know I do have some respect you know
it's just the kind of place you wouldn't
even touch yourself in or hell I
wouldn't even write a letter I wouldn't
even write myself a love note in there
you know it just has that kind of
comfort in there and in beauty and
there's a big picture of art on the wall
and I don't even know what the hell it
is but it looks expensive but it was
nice watch the fights had a little bit
of sea bass over there because rich
people eat different fish man I like
fish that is Ryu know that you can
actually get a hold of carp you know
what else catfish
sunfish eel if you do an eel right bro
then I'll do a damn meal baby you feel
me
look barbecued eel that's something I
don't mind you start some a1 on one of
them [ __ ] slick little pond phalanges
baby I'll suck that thing down god damn
I will suck that thing face-first bro
you put that big beautiful eel out there
with a little BB Q on it
when a couple honey-roasted peanuts
brought to chase it down whoo hmmm we
doing it but that's what I did man you
know I went over to somebody Rich's
house and watched the fights and
actually I went over to Jionni we got
the twink Jionni he's back in town so we
went over I went over with him and Nick
and watched a little bit of the fights -
producer Nick and but we'll talk a
little bit more about the fights
whenever we got Dustin on in a little
while and talk a little bit more about
UFC yeah what else I don't know the
world's getting back you know we're all
being kind of reborn a little you feel
that a little bit and some people is
afraid to come out of the womb some
people wants to stay in the womb some
people want to just go outside of the
womb because we've all kind of been like
womb mates for a while and that's
running out and there's a lot of
disparity out there right now people
want to some people want to start living
life again and go back to the old days
and some people want to just you know
kick it up a notch and be natural or
some people want to just stay like you
know quarantined and there's an here's
the thing in in this country both people
you can do both that's the thing about
America that's it you know it would
almost be more helpful during a pandemic
if you lived in a country that was
socialist or communist because what what
they say goes there's no there's no
joking around there's no ifs ands or
buts but we don't live in that place you
know we live in a place where everybody
has a say and that's what's going on
right now and people say well these
people are wrong or these people well
neither one of them are
I mean they may be wrong to me or they
may be wrong to you but you know
everybody has a sayin and you know like
the government can't just tell people
that they can't do things they just
can't do that I mean and everybody I
feel like has given this disease they've
you know the virus they've you know I
feel like we've done a good job of
planning ahead the only thing we could
have done was take these measures you
know we had to take the measures that
have been taken if it's rainin bro you
could even if you like the rain you
might want to start off by putting on a
raincoat just to you know how long it's
gonna rain what its gonna feel like will
there be lightning you know am I gonna
be trying to smoke a cigarette what's
gonna what it's going to go on during
this ring and then once you have a plan
then you can take the coat off if you
want some people want to take their
coats off some people want to stay in
the coat and both of them are right
that's what I think both I'm writing
this I need something I think it's just
the way it is
I personally I'm more of a risky biscuit
you know something if you see if you
smell my back you're gonna smell a bunch
of risk jelly because that's what God
spread on me you know he put that damn
sweet risk paste right on my damn skin
and that's who I am
you know what I'm ready I'm ready to
take you know let's take some chances
I'm ready to roll the dice I don't know
it I don't even I just think that's what
you know cuz I grew up in a place we had
rabies going around we had dangerous dog
come and bite you you know we didn't
have a virus but we'd have a dog come
through town by 7 or 18 people a name
you get hit by that dog yeah I didn't
get hit but my grandfather did oh yeah
my cousin got bit by that dog
m-yeah he killed two chickens at our
house and and he got my aunt like damn
so I grew up an area where things were
passing through that would that few up
you know we'd have like dangerous nails
back when they had tetanus she had to
get a tetanus shot
because 3040 people step on the same
sharp nail in town oh you know you'd
have a 30 40 different people step on
the same nail so I grew up in a kind of
place I'm look I tell mother nature
bring it on throw that battle-ax mother
nature because I'm ready to get out
there now it may be risky but like I
said I'm a risky biscuit
that's the baking soda I got inside of
me is risk powder and some people don't
some people more safety some people was
raised you know you know and they they
they got a library inside of them and
everything they got all you know they
want it to be like this and this and
this and hey that's okay it might be
different than me but I'll live with
those people so you know I respect what
they want to do but but they also have
to like I'm not going to be ignorant
about the way I live but I'm gonna live
you know I feel like I just want to live
but it's tough because we all have to be
careful we're not endangering each other
you know it's a unique time but people
are ready people are getting back out
there people are taking on new
experiences and uh and taking on old
experiences man we got a couple calls
that came in I'm gonna get into some of
it the hotline as always as nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
what's up max from Texas down there and
yeah Elon Musk said he might be moving
his plant down to Texas because he has
issues
the way that they're governing the the
lockdown here in in California homeward
and well I'm gonna fan for about two
years now
Thank You Man thank you for the support
brother that's nice of you man but um
I'm 15 years old and that's important
because man I'm getting the job and the
bust one actually and I know you in a
Billiken court Oh were Busboys and
around my age so I don't know man I'm
really anxious about dude um I'm going
to help my mom during this corvid time
dude but uh I'm gonna send me back some
advice gang [ __ ] well you know gang brah
and I love you too brother and I'm glad
look I'm glad first and foremost are you
taking on new opportunity to help out
your mother you know Mother's Day really
is it's a it's a that Mother's Day just
a reminder that's just lighting the fuse
the rest of the year is that candle baby
where we try to keep it burning for our
mother and it's hard it's a hard
relationship sometimes but I love
hearing this man this makes me feel this
reminds me that I'm a son and then I
want to help out my mother as well and
look I'll tell you man bus Boyan first
of all you have to remember that when
you start out as a busboy if if you
start out like I started out bees to the
dub baby balls-to-the-wall son you know
what I'm saying nuts
I mean just nuts to the frickin drywall
I mean I started out just I was I was
cruising we had bread over there brah
waters who needs tea bro and we had two
different types of tea that was the
thing and one of the pitchers had a
little orange slice on it a quarter
orange slice on a tip of the pitcher and
the other one didn't so if people got
that tropical passion tea you had to get
that orange slice picture hit him with
that one and if they got that basic ass
tea you know you had to hit him with
that regular picture
and we had that in water those were the
three pictures we had so I'm running
regular tees I'm running passion tees
and then we had these kind of a very
light Banana Nut muffin in these very
light banana nut muffins it was a um get
to replace the tray and then someone
they had butter sometime you know big
big Lawrence or somebody big big uh big
uh big Bernadette roll in there and they
throw six butters on a muffin like down
on a half a month and they cut it in
half and stacked that [ __ ] up with that
month idea that butter so then we got to
hit him with that butter bam bam bam but
it was constantly just moving and
shaking but yet I had the apron I was
cruising I had the rag stuffed in the
corner you know and I one wet rag in one
dry way one dry rag so I was ready for
anything and I was smiling I was
cruising I was hyped I was excited but
what I'm telling you is this if you
start out at a new position as a busboy
you want to start out with some
enthusiasm you want to but if you start
out balls-to-the-wall they're always
going to expect balls-to-the-wall and
what happened to me was over years you
know how you ended up using steroids and
creatine to enhance my performance and
uh because that was my sport man in high
school that was my sport man being a
busboy getting that minimum wage you
know pocketing that M dubbed a B and so
I was next thing you know I'm using D
ball I'm using winstram on test 200 test
240 some real questionable [ __ ] that
came out for a little while but what I'm
saying is if you start with if he
started a level 10 they'll always expect
that level 10 so if I could go back in
time I'd have started at a level eight
I'd have known I was capable of ten
and I would have ramped it up around
there from about maybe 8:30 to 9:45
during the heat hours or peak times they
called it peak business times that's
when I were to ramped up my ability and
then I were to ramped it down the rest
of the time because I burnt out you know
I have to add two years I'm having to do
you know I'm on creatine I'm on you know
I'm on uppers bruh I'm you know I'm
meeting up with people after work doing
draw like I I just got burnt out cuz I
but I was a dog I was Allen Iverson of
[ __ ] dirty tables that's who I was
and anybody in Tucson will tell you that
that knew about that in like early 2000s
so that's all I would say man go in
there be passionate and a but have that
extra gear you can always go into and if
I could go back in time that's how I
would do it I'd have that extra gear
because I kind of ran out of it man I'm
looking at this video they got robots in
Singapore in the park
I don't know if you saw this thing it's
like a little electric dog it's like a
little you know this little just a damn
it looks like a damn future it looked
like somebody took a piece of the future
and just threw it in a park and it goes
around and tells people they're too
close together and kind of videos it
looks like a video records also what is
going on in the park unless people know
if they're in a group that they need to
be at least one meter apart if you saw
this video or not and it's just it's an
electronic it's a robot and what I don't
like about a personal doesn't have a
head so it looks extremely it has that
whole futuristic look in every now and
then on Facebook they'll come out with
something real future
eristic that just it kind of looks like
it's just to scare you like this is what
its gonna be like but that's in
Singapore man okay you let that [ __ ]
loose in Baltimore somebody somebody
will first of all we'll have that thing
we'll have that
somebody will have that thing fighting a
pitbull in five minutes bro
you let that [ __ ] loose in Baltimore
first of all somebody else will be
mating that thing do my buddy sach field
he'll mate that thing with a damn
Australian Shepherd you have a couple
little uh you know you'll have a couple
of arty r2d2 s about six weeks later huh
however long it takes to make a dog baby
but yeah I don't think this is the wave
of the future I think that this is
something that's kind of spooky about
science because in some countries people
aren't people are gonna listen to this
animal to this robot animal but not here
dude if that thing comes close to
somebody they're gonna pull out a UH a
weapon on it due to a couple crackheads
who [ __ ] melt that thing's leg down
and sell it sell the copper out of that
mf'er so I I just think you know you got
a unique deal here but I don't think
that this thing's something anybody
needs to be scared of not here not in
the US ma'am but it's definitely pretty
fascinating a Boston Dynamics robot
named spot was deployed in Singapore to
help police citizens during their
nationwide corvid lockdown spot roams
around public spaces and reminds people
of social distancing rules and is
equipped with cameras and analytic tools
to observe how many people are in given
space breaches of Singapore's strict
lockdown rules can result in fines or
jail yep and that's fine but let me just
tell you this you let that thing loose
over there on McGhee street where I grew
up bro somebody will steal that a little
MF ROS leg bra and uh
and put that thing and and and use that
thing somehow in a damn Toyota Tercel
somebody somebody do somebody melt that
little bastard down and make a hubcap
for a freaking 88 Camry in a heartbeat
bruh and that's factual
so in Singapore yeah in Baltimore this
little month this little MF ro get
carjacked in a heartbeat
what else went on in the news man oh
yeah
Elon Musk I was talking about earlier
talking about moving Tesla out of
California following extended
shelter-in-place rules
local California officials refused to
let Tesla reopen its Fremont factory
Tesla has filed a lawsuit against
Alameda County Elon Musk threatened to
move Tesla's headquarters to Texas or
Nevada where shelter-in-place rules are
less restrictive Elon Musk tweeted the
unelected and ignorant interim health
officer of Alameda is acting contrary to
the governor the president and our
constitutional freedoms and just plain
common sense he said frankly this is the
final straw Tesla is the last car maker
left in California I think you're gonna
run into stuff like this because you
know business owners business operators
they want to they want a business
business people want a business and they
we live in a free market where people
can business and so when a government
comes in at a certain point says all you
can't business you know I think you're
gonna get you this is what you're gonna
get you're gonna get people to say
that's fine I'm gonna go to a state that
is a little bit more along the lines
with the way that I want to do business
and I say more power to that you know
I'm all for a little bit more for state
governments you know I'd love to see
more
you know this is this state and this is
the way that they like to do things
because we're such a we're such a people
that you know people have so many ideas
now and everybody has a platform now to
share their ideas and how they think and
what they like that I feel like there
that there should be almost more option
more options I wish that everybody were
just we are America but that doesn't
seem to be the way that it is anymore
and so I think if you have a bunch of
different kind of smaller types of
America within states then people can
say ok this state is more to my liking
this is where I want to do my business
this is more what I'm in line with and I
think you're gonna get that you know
especially California in California you
know it's very liberal and you know they
try to kind of cater to you know always
help the lowest common denominator or
give everybody you know they want to
help everyone and I love it I love it in
theory but sometimes in practicality
it's not always you know I don't feel
like there's a lot of you also need to
help yourself whereas some states I feel
like there's a bit more in the
constituents or a customer in there in
there in the ball bag of each of that
state that says earn the Aubree's that
says hey you know we'll help you you
also have to help yourself
you also need to do things for yourself
so yeah I think it's neat that there's
if that if any business want to go with
it and then they have the ability to do
that but I'm not surprised you know I'm
not surprised it's interesting too
because in in California a lot of
businesses are so you know people are
very there's a strong sense of okay
everyone needs to wear a mask our
stronger sense here than there are in
other places that I've been and I'm
living mostly in the Hollywood area so
but I see I hear a strong sense of okay
we need to wear masks you have your mask
on want to have your mask on but now
some businesses aren't going to be able
to come back because they're not going
to be able to make enough money like a
restaurant you know in a neighborhood
where it costs them you know $20,000 a
month for their rent now if they have to
keep tables six feet apart or whatever
they're not going to be able to survive
because they're not gonna have enough
tables in their restaurant so it's just
like you have places that it's almost
like their own extremely or their own
more liberal rules are now eating up
their own businesses if that makes any
sense and sometimes I don't know what
I'm talking about and I always don't
know what I'm talking about um but but
it's like okay well these are this is
the way it needs to be we need to follow
all these guidelines and now the
guidelines have it so they can't even
run their own businesses anymore whereas
you have other places you know I was in
Utah last week and they're just like hey
let's rock you know let's rock
so that's America though people can you
can do it different ways but businesses
are also going to be able to decide okay
I want to do my business in the place
where they're a little bit more or less
rock or a little or they're a little bit
more no we can't rock because these are
the rules and both of those are okay I'm
excited to talk about these fights man
we're gonna do it in just a few minutes
I got to let you know that today's
episode is brought to you by blue chew
and if you want to get in the ring with
your wife or if you if you love men and
you prefer a sexual man and you want to
get in a ring with a sex man and touch
that man or if you want to get a woman
and y'all be naked
each other if you want to have any
erection during any of that then then I
have to let you know that this episode
is sponsored by blue Chu and we're
grateful to them and look even if you
don't have a problem in erection grab
you a couple of blue shoes surprise the
lady throw one in he'll give one to your
freaking cousin have him come by not for
a threesome but just to show off that
work you know tell your lady hey I love
you so much I gave you no I gave you no
I gave to a tease to Steven and look
what he's doing over there you know I'm
saying he can paint without using his
hands look at him but that's what I'm
telling you you can increase your
performance and get that extra
confidence in bed blue to calm that's
blue like the color blue blue to brings
you the first chewable with the same
fda-approved active ingredients as
Viagra and Cialis you can take them any
time day or night even on a full stomach
and since they're chewable they work up
to twice as fast as a pill so you can be
ready whenever an opportunity arises if
you could benefit from more confidence
where it counts blue chew is the fast
and easy way to enhance your performance
yup blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed physicians so you don't have to
go to the doctor's office or wait in
line at the pharmacy don't you hear that
and it ships right to your door in a
discreet package so they send you in
that surprise package it could be
something though people what is that or
you got a pinata what's in it they're
gonna think candy but hey Wiener candy
they're made in the USA amen and since
blue chip repairs and ships directly
they're cheaper than a pharmacy and best
of all there's no more awkwardness
there's no more awkwardness man you
don't have to meet your buddy in an
alley or meet a brother on the dance
floor you know say hey you know hey quo
various you got that big you know you
got that that big pecker brought loan me
a little bit let me get that chew off of
you right now we have a special deal for
our listeners
at blue chu dot-com and get your first
shipment free when you use our special
promo code th EO just pay five dollars
shipping again that's B lu e CH e w.com
promo code th e o to try it for free
blue chu it's the better cheaper faster
choice and we thank them for sponsoring
the podcast go and support this past
weekend this episode is brought to you
by better help better help will assess
your needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist you can
start communicating with your therapist
in under 24 hours you know I was having
quite a day one time and quite a time
one day and I was driving somewhere man
and I couldn't get my brain I was angry
somebody had called me something I think
called me a little [ __ ] or something I
called me a little hussy you know and
damn it hurt me damn it hurt me and I
didn't know what to do and I just wanted
to run my damn car off the road or just
driving to a [ __ ] Wendy's Drive right
into the back of a Wendy's but instead I
hit up better help and within minutes I
was on a FaceTime call with a therapist
and she was able to talk me into some
comfort and then I was able to go on
about my day it's not a crisis line it's
not self-help it is professional
counseling done securely there's a broad
range of expertise and better helps
counselor network which may not be
locally available in many areas the
services available for clients worldwide
you can log into your account at any
time and send a message to your
counselor better help is committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy and free to change
counselors if needed it's more
affordable than traditional offline
counseling and financial aid is
available and look those are really nice
things we all need help
everybody we all need help
better help wants you to start living a
happier life today visit better help
calm slash th e oh that's B e TT ER h e
LP and join the over half a million
people taking charge of their mental
health with the help of an experienced
professional special offer for this past
weekend listeners get 10% off your first
month at better help calm / Theo oh man
getting through this episode the world
is starting back you know it's funny
some people don't want the world to open
back up because I feel like it gives
them a sense of control over others I
just notice this I have some friends who
say no no no but I don't think I think
they're just thinking it gives them this
oh then they can control what happens
now you know it gives them like they get
to control everybody some of us it's
like a sense you know we don't want to
go we don't want to have to be
responsible I think there's a part of me
that's like dang let's keep it like this
you know I don't have to be respond I
don't have to
you know there's no that the system is
down the sit the the checks and balances
is all gone that the rat race isn't
there I don't have to you know I can
just be lazy I can take it easy out you
know it's been it's been a break so yeah
I guess there's a difference there
between it's been a break and do I and
am I being do I just want to keep being
able to be lazy you know but there's
part of me that definitely feels that I
call this break is nice you know I'm
afraid if things start back up and I'm
gonna have to be you know back into
competing for a job and competing for
this and trying for that and you know I
think there's a little part of me that's
I call oh yeah well I guess there's been
nice to not have to do that it's just so
there's so many little things going on
throughout this whole core of it man
gang bro let's take another call they
came right here corvid positive from
gentlemen homeward what's up Sergio and
that's Spanish for Serge I guess our
sergeant I'm living in Dallas now and I
want to I was listening to the podcast
and I was hearing that oh you can to get
somebody with some positive that
happiness and so I didn't want to let
you know man you know I changed my whole
life around I started smoking weed about
14 or 20 mm and I teach my whole life
around I even got a little hooked with a
little yeah you know at 81 Rico but I
got I got all that I got rid of all that
man and okay he's off the dope he's off
the bag baby and uh ser he owes off that
bag gang [ __ ] homework I lost 100 pounds
you know and just like before the whole
chorus thing happened you know like you
say out I take my whole life round in
this crazy that I left me
York in January right before this went
down so I wanted to get your essays my
whole life I'm trying to get back
together with my wife we got separated
we're trying to get back together and
we're trying to we're trying to be good
together clearly more so and there you
go listen to that you know this is a
yeah people have used this opportunity
to adjust to recalibrate to look at
things and that's beautiful man and
Thank You Sergio for that call you know
that's a beautiful call to get from your
brother let's take another right there
the hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three I feel it's Lia
from not Julia to see hey Lia thank you
for calling from Mount Joliet Albert and
it is currently 4:30 in the morning and
I just finished high school it's really
weird I didn't think that I would finish
high school on my bedroom floor but I
did and I finished it I said my last
final while watching your latest episode
back from outdoors and dying of laughter
as always yeah oh well thank you Leah
yeah I think that yeah somebody finished
in their high school the end of the end
of high school and you just been at home
you're on the floor you know it says uh
well hell I remember then the high
school we had a dance I guess it was
prom and a buddy of mine the Spanish
teacher grabbed his uh dick penis wiener
so you know the guy had tried to for
years and [ __ ] and uh and finally he
kind of my buddy just kind of let him
you know they were they were everybody
was drunk it was at the dance and and he
just kind of let him [ __ ] hold it for
a little um not in like a homoerotic way
just like in a specialty human way hey
buddy you know yeah finally I'll let you
look at this bro you know but just give
it back and so there's two ways to look
at it Leah you know you know there's a
way at least you're in the safety of
your own home you're finishing a paper
you know you know it's 4:30 you can go
back to sleep
meanwhile my buddy is getting uh you
know sexually accosted by a man you know
a fake Spanish man so gang baby what
else we got this call that came in right
here hey what's up Bo it's Richie
down here New Iberia Louisiana Oh Richie
from New Iberia and that's actually
extremely close to where uh Dustin
Poirier lives and we're gonna be on on
zoom with him in just a few minutes
homeward and I was just thinking you
know I want to hear what you thought
about you know names people name their
children and what name you know
basically guarantees that your kid is
going to turn out a certain way you know
back in the day you know people would
name their kid
Bertha that was a popular name and then
I think at some point people realized if
you name your little girl Bertha she's
gonna be fat she's probably gonna be fat
I can't name a skinny person and then I
was you know
yeah Bertha you know what oftenly lend
itself to a large nosotros Albert think
about like Shane Shane's a name you see
a lot of and I don't know how about
where you was over in Covington but I
know where you know all the research
I've ever done anytime you see a dude
named Shane he's up to them Dark Arts
he's probably doing some some
mischievous things he's huffing freon
he's stealing some nice propane tank and
yeah throwing it at him me
yeah Shane is a sneaky er name Oh Shane
over there you know sipping coolant you
know Shane over there huffing that gas
baby getting that Astro head you know
just I just
frickin ass throwing up his old lung
holes yeah yeah different names
different for sure I agree with you
there I'm trying to think of a couple
right now cliff you know you call a
somebody cliff you name them cliff
that's dangerous because if they get
into their own name it's gonna they're
gonna go to a mountain they're gonna go
to a quarry they might take that chance
brother might take that leap you know
whereas if you name somebody Candida you
know if they get involved in her own
name they may be gonna get a cavity they
may you know it's a more limited I'm a
different name for sure you know we had
a raw sugar Roy we had this guy bus as
guy and he could have been a gay man but
he was still a child but um but they
would call him sugar Roy and Roy
sometimes can have that that type of
name you know a little bit more sugar
and a tank a Ricky they call him tricky
Ricky maybe he does magic he does tricks
or a licky licky Ricky they call him a
leaky Ricky he'll lick anything put
something by him see if he'll wet it up
with his tongue with that liquor well we
had a guy named Jeep this dude he was
dangerous as [ __ ] and he was named after
Jeep man and I remember he couldn't get
a driver's license as we got older
because they kept thought he fell out
the paperwork wrong because he'd write
Jeep in as his name but that was his
damn name but yes certain names Dexter
that could be a nerdy name Darcy that's
a library named Winston he gonna smoke
you know splinter he gonna probably do
lumber you know
mark he gonna probably chalk up the
football field before the games so
everybody you know that yeah a name
could be definitely a different one you
know a name could lead you a certain
type of way some type of way all right
let's take one more call here before we
get into hitting up the diamond Dustin
Poirier here and um and this gentleman
right here at a call in that came into
the hotline that hit me
gang homework hey Colin from Rochester
New York
what's up Rust Belt and you up there
Rochester baby the ROC and shout out to
my boy Baggins that died out there
outside of a Days Inn I think yeah man
Rochester baby home at a neck tattoo
dude home at a neck tattoo and a lot of
white dudes shooting three-pointers bruh
five pointers gang Robert ladies podcast
here and you saying Americans getting
soft and I took exception to that
because because maybe some are but but
this one ain't I slept outside for 10
years 10 solid years I lived on park
benches had attempt by the highway
staircases the parking garage staircases
one winter it was so cold I'd check out
a psych ward because I went crazy
damn well yeah you're right man on my
bad dude yeah I hate being cold and
crazy that's the worst isn't it isn't
that the worst man when you [ __ ] you
losing your mind and you [ __ ]
freezing cold I hate that [ __ ] you're
like I'm singing ghosts you right Johnny
man my bad dude a lot of people holding
it down a lot of people are tough gang
you know bum fights all sorts of stuff
so not not every American living that
soft life you know keep that in mind man
and a lot of people work hard you right
man
you write bro you know I'm out here in
soft gana stand man and you know in
Hollyweird I got to remember that you
know I'm out here where it's just me
really my meeting only perception I have
is my own some speaking from my own way
of life really man but gang bruh and
stay warm daddy get that coat all right
let's get this oh here's another call
from New York I want to get this in a
little bit more I know I've been talking
a little bit about the disease today and
and and how we're bouncing back from it
and if you have any calls or suggestions
or constructive criticisms of things
that I've said feel free to hit the
hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three onward this is
Johnny from Long Island what's up Johnny
hoping you give me some advice was
getting to a pretty dark place my dad
died a few weeks ago from coronavirus
yeah I was again into a pretty bad trip
saying like that guy who called three
days ago who's bad died uh nurses family
member died of colon cancer hmm I
thought I'd call you
man I'm sorry brother
man I'm sorry to hear that about that
about your father man uh you know let me
let me see if I can't get you on the
line Johnny boy I got your number right
here I want to hear a little more
hey Johnny
what up man is this Theo von man I got
your voicemail on the voice machine yeah
man I'm just real sorry to hear about
your father
[Music]
word man well thanks for saying that
dude yeah sometimes it's easier than
others man sometimes you know when life
gets hectic and stuff it's hard to I
don't know sometimes it's hard to just
keep everything kind of cruising you
know and with your father pretty was he
pretty ill take me through some of that
man cuz what a surprise that he had that
he had korvac
yeah yeah um you got it was all like
really quick really really quick yeah
you got it in the beginning of April oh
and he had it for like a week at home
and like we thought he was doing fine
pretty healthy guy he was 65 and he
smoked for most of his life he exercised
over throughout the hospital and then
they put him into a coma do you think
the man gosh dude I'm so sorry man you
guys were pretty close I got my first
like real job and he was really proud of
me immigrant from the USSR so
basically like he achieved his like
American dream
he had like his son like guess it's like
jobs so IQs we got we got really close
yeah wow man that's amazing that you
guys are you know had some you know had
some stuff that you know kind of some
achievements it sounds like in this past
year yeah I'm so sorry man I just it's
just such a shock in I guess
were you guys evil able to able to have
a funeral or anything like that and you
didn't ever say so in that Jesus and it
was like just a pine box yeah oh yeah
yeah I've been to some of those man it's
a basic it's definitely a basic drop
piece but it's uh yeah you want
something a little flashier I feel like
was your dad a pretty flashy guy oh yeah
yeah
oh man that's why that uh damn man what
yeah man I wish there was something
especially we could do man I wish that
uh you know I I think it's amazing
you're able to be there for your younger
brother how how old is he yeah well wish
you luck man I'll definitely check in
and see what's going on and and thanks
for sharing with me man and you know I
mean obviously a lot of the regular
stuff just you know keep your spirits up
and just know you're not alone and and
uh yeah it's wild how your dad came all
he came here to America and now you're
here like first generation that's pretty
crazy man it's you know it's interesting
how like sometimes our parents have to
really make that sacrifice or make a big
move so we can have some opportunity but
I'll be thinking of you Johnny man and I
appreciate the call brother all right
you too man keep keep your head up man I
love you bro dang bro oh man you don't
you don't you hate that like when
sometimes like Pete you know somebody's
having a tough time you just don't know
what to say you know and it doesn't
matter something you can say you know
sometimes it's not about saying anything
it's just you know letting somebody know
you care you let them know you care man
but yeah you're going through all of
this and then your dad goes to heaven at
the same time it's a lot of and there's
international travel restrictions can
you even get to heaven right now you
know what are the rules you know and
then you take the flashy dad in your you
got your brother your cousin or whatever
kind of skimps on the you know I can't
believe they wouldn't the funeral parlor
themselves should put the guy in a nice
cast
you know but there's something also
beautiful about going over rolling up to
heaven in this that basic stroller bra
and that basic frickin body boat you
know that plywood freakin in that
plywood you know rectangle ambience
there's something kind of you know
there's something kind of everyman about
it you know now he's like an immigrant
in heaven man you know now your dad's
like a new I mean if there's anybody
that could survive heading into a new
place obviously you know that it's him I
mean he came here and did it you know
another beauty of this country people
can come here and live their dreams and
achieve their dreams
you know people can come here and raise
their son to be you know what sounds
like a very good young man you know
there's a lot of beautiful things that
that that can go on in this country and
and that that's the freedoms
that's the freedoms people are allowed
to do these things you know so I wonder
what his dad would have wanted I wonder
what his dad would have wanted
I asked him I asked him one more time
how his dad felt hey Johnny man I have
one more question bro I was just
thinking about your dad I was wondering
do you think he would have liked was he
more like kind of scared of coronavirus
or was he more like let's get out there
and do you wish you would have taken it
seriously or do you are you like that's
my dad
[Music]
word man yeah I was just curious just
curious about because you know people
just have there's just different schools
of thought on how to handle it and but
no this is I think it's just important
to hear man well appreciate it man I'll
be thinking of you do it I'll be in
touch man oh I love you too many good
Wow
it's interesting it's risky you know
it's risky and there's risky biscuits in
the oven baby
there's risky biscuits in the oven
there's nothing riskier then then I
don't think fighting for your life man
and that's what um that's what our next
guest does and and he's one of a kind
and he is he has been the the interim
lightweight champion and he we're gonna
give get him on a zoom call in just a
moment should I put on some Bob nah what
cologne I think you gonna say Cologne I
mean that's cool
[Laughter]
Dustin the diamond Poirier man good to
see you bro
good to see you too man I like that
change oh thank you very much brought us
that old carnival chain baby yeah buddy
pick the animal on the wall yeah baby
how you feeling today good good yeah man
I just got home about an hour so going
eight we've got a good wrestling
practice in this morning man I'm grinded
nice man
yeah I saw you all the UFC putting your
tweets up and stuff the other night
during the fight how did it feel to be
watching fights again man it felt good
it
freaking motivated me do it motivated me
so much I woke up the next day with a
different pep in my step you know I'm I
want to fight and I want to I want to
show the world what I can do man when
you were watching the fights was there
any part during the fights really like
where without the crowd being there
you're like wow that must have been
totally different or what are some
things that kind of stood out to you
that were either surprising or even
humorous even oh I was surprised at how
patient and calculated gate she was when
he had Tony hurts a few times you know I
think the gay Chi of old would have just
ran in through Kosh to the win and tried
to finish him and maybe got
himself but he was very composed I'm not
sure if that had anything to do with the
crowd not being there maybe he's a guy
who feeds off the crowd ah you know
because the crowds going nuts and you
might just follow their lead
yeah just angry bird in there yeah
but uh you know he had a great
performance dude showed a lot of growth
in it since his last few fights and uh
you know hats off to him he's a man yeah
you called that fight I saw um what made
you going into that when you're like oh
I I feel like he's got this I just
thought that Tony makes a lot of
mistakes and I didn't think if I was
gonna go to the ground I thought it was
gonna be a stand-up fight which it was
uh I just you know Tony's been hurt in a
lot of fights he said Tony actually
surprising man he's way more durable
than I thought he was Wow
he's been dropped by pedis land over
nada
a few guys he's been hurt by he gets
hurt on almost every fight yeah but
their incredible durability man what a
warrior boy what would was uh was there
any moment in the fight was there any
moment in a fight where like does a
fight ever get going so good where you
wish you were in it or the fight going
so good where you're like oh man I'm
glad I'm not in that no I like that type
of stuff of course I don't want to get
my brain beat up but when fights like
the gay Chi Tony fight or hat is
happening that was kind of more one-way
traffic but it was a great fight yeah
during those type of fights I just you
know I always go to sleep after watching
those fights and just pray that I get a
chance to be in one of those type of
fights and show the world you know that
my grit and my fortitude in there they
know when I watch fights like that I I
just want to be part of that violence
man wow that is the total opposite how I
feel I would take this the man I was
very surprised with the Charles Russell
fight with your buddy yeah because in
you know Charles I trained with Charles
and he has good jujitsu and he
completely got shut down you know like
oh what the yeah because you guys work
with American Top Team right
yeah yeah and I've been training with
Charles probably since 2012 I've been
rolling with him and training alongside
him while he doesn't
he does have very high-level jujitsu do
you think he was just shocked do you
think that he I mean I think everybody
was kind of shocked that Bryce was able
to pull off that type of you know just I
mean he turned in almost just like a
cricket you know like I mean he was just
you know he was a fright there he was
sunken in yeah I think what really
surprised Rosa I think is the Rice's top
pressure just his control on top and
being able to continue to get Charles
down like that that was not no I was
surprised man I was really surprising
that fire yeah yeah it was an exciting
night of fights um towards the end of
the night did you I mean you like your
division lightweights like it's a
there's so many stars and you guys's
division after the did you have any
difference of who you wanted to fight
like her who you would like to see for
your next fight before the gate chief
Ferguson bout and then after did that
change um you know I always wanted to
get in there with Tony but but he's
injured I believe he broke his orbital
in that fight so he's gonna be out a
little while gate she's obviously gonna
sit and wait for khabib to be out of
ramadhan and they able to fight again
which I heard them talking about uh July
or August maybe and I seen a couple
tweets about that time frame so I kind
of knew I thought possibly the loser of
that fight uh I could fight again you
know if gates you would have lost the
rematch would have made sense and also
if Tony would have just lost and not
been injured the rematch are not the
rematch but that fight would have made
sense so I really have no clue what do
you see what direction they're gonna go
man but I want to fight yeah do you
think it's kind of unfair it seems like
everybody's willing to fight except for
Connor kind of and this look I'm just a
layperson I'm was just a fan and not
even a great and I'm and I'm also afraid
to fight people but uh but it seems like
from just a fans point of view that
Connor gets kind of put in this
different not class but he gets a
different treatment kind of a little bit
does it feel like that as a fighter or
no yeah he gets the he gets the pick
when and who and and where he fights and
he's done a great job of maximizing his
earning potential and it is a business
right but if he's out there complaining
about the rankings in any other sport
what you do is you compete against the
next person in the rankings to climb
yeah so let's [ __ ] go
yeah are you feeling like um that it's
gonna be hard to cut weight like were
you noticing that as you get along your
career that you're like oh man that to
get down in 155 is gonna be tough yeah
it's very tough the last few weight cuts
were pretty hard to fight with khabib
the weight cut was a little easier on me
because I put so much into it and focus
so much on it because I thought it was
gonna be a grueling fight and I knew I
was traveling across the world so I just
wanted to make sure I had that part of
the fight camp down so we went the extra
mile and I brought in a nutritionist for
the last few weeks and and we made there
you made every meal for me for the last
few weeks of camp and that really helped
me but it's not easy man getting down to
155 is very hard for me and so and
that's the only like so for you guys is
a weight class that's where you have to
fight at right 155 155 yeah if I jumped
up I'd have to fight at 170 pounds and
those guys are even bigger you know
those guys are walking around 200 pounds
so your next fight will you have any
control over that do you have a say-so
in it is the hooker fight still on do
you know you know they wanted us to
fight May 16th then they talked a little
bit about switching our fight to here in
Florida when all the stuff got scrambled
because we were originally supposed to
fight out in California in San Diego
then we're gonna let us fight at a
higher weight class they were gonna let
us fight at 170 because the lack of
preparation and training it just didn't
work out that fight didn't work out it
was rushed I didn't want to you know
fight outside the weight class it was a
bunch of weird things and if they want
to book it I'll fight him you know I
just want to fight right whoever I need
to fight to show these guys that I'm
still the best you know the best the top
in line to get another title shot I want
to fight you know I just need to win
you're ready I'm ready yeah
so how many weeks notice do you think
you need to be ready for a fight or
hours dude I'll tell you what there's
like one roll of toilet paper at the
Publix and there's you know somebody and
we're about the same distance and we
start spreading I mean I'm gonna fight
you're ready but I do four weeks
give me four weeks I'll be ready yeah
and that's quickly you know yeah so as
so as right now then so the hooker fight
isn't definite it's not
on right now right now your anything
could happen anything could happen and
but I came to South Florida mm-hmm
you know a week ago just to start
preparing because I knew I want to fight
and I know they're gonna start pumping
out these cards now that they had their
first event back I think they're gonna
keep them rolling and I'm gonna be ready
when the opportunity comes how soon do
you think it could be until you have a
two-year and I have an idea of your next
bout I actually Saturday night after the
fights I sort of blown up Dana yeah they
know I joined show me you know just kept
texting them they told me I'm fighting
next month so let's go Wow yeah they
didn't tell me who that's exciting
though man that's dope man what if you
and I might have just gonna like give
this crazy pass I look at my phone yeah
you'll fight tomorrow yeah
there's not even a fight part tomorrow
dude what what have you been doing
during the quarantine I know you've been
staying busy training cuz I'll check on
you I'll see your videos on IG and stuff
what else what else have you been up to
besides training well I've only been
here a week so I've been home with my
family for the most part since I got
here I've just been training and playing
PlayStation but my wife and daughter
come to meet me this weekend so um huh
man two weeks is my limit I can't do two
weeks without oh yeah and any new little
Poirier kids on the books or what man
y'all got another little one in the oven
no not yet but uh it's coming yeah when
you don't shoot for a boy can't really
pick it but we'll see what happens yeah
I know you love being a day man sweet
pea looks pretty damn tough though she
is pretty tough she likes to wrestle man
I bought our trampoline
you know the trampoline with the cage
around it yeah of course you look of
course in your family you put a cage
around anything man you guys are ready
to go so so but overall do you feel like
just watching those fights yell denied
it just really got you amped up and
ready to rock huh
yeah I I went to sleep Saturday night
and woke up Sunday more focused I felt
like something clicked you know I got my
my calendar I started writing stuff down
started writing a time frame down went
for a run woke up early today
got my whole day plan cooked my food for
the day I started a diet you know I'm
ready let's go let's go um were you
shocked at UFC was like the first sport
back I know they wanted to man I know
Dana's a trailblazer and he
he likes to set records and and and be
the first to do things and I really
thought he was gonna do it I thought it
was gonna be the other card that got
cancelled in April I believe mhm I
thought they were I thought they were
gonna go through with that I just know
Dana how hard he pushes and and rallies
to get things going and but he is his
first sport back man
yeah word man well uh in a pay-per-view
you know in a time where everybody's
home and everybody's still cheering from
the NFL Draft you know if they're
getting that kind of ratings I'm sure
the pay-per-view did well I know huh do
you um I had the question what happens
if if d if DC fights are in Ghana oh I
don't know man
I don't know we saw steep a outwrestle
in Ghana but that was a little bit you
know a little while back you know
Daniels a he's a heavyweight but he's
not a big guy he is not he's like my
height he might be an inch taller than
me
Wow yeah yeah and and in Ghana is a huge
human being
dude he's big and I'm friends with
Daniel he can get it done but that's you
know one mistake in you but he was a
Strikeforce Grand Prix heavyweight
champion you know he beat a bunch of
other former champions too so win that
belt that in Ghana guys scary though man
dude man his arms are like long cars he
has like limousines in his arms right
you say that they said like his punching
power was equal to like a Ford Taurus or
something so I don't know him do the
numbers but I guess that's a pretty good
car to be compared to that's a lot man
um have you ever have you been on uh
Mike Tyson's podcast no I mean I would
love to go I would love to go yes you
like some of you would uh that you would
be on rent yeah that Tyson ranch bruh
after the fight man he serving the
salads with marijuana and I'm over there
bro well dude I'm so excited for you man
thanks for jumping on I just wanted to
kind of touch base and just kind of see
what you were thinking after the fight
man obviously you really enjoyed it was
what was the biggest surprise to you of
the evening you think honestly the
biggest surprise was was uh Tony's
durability because he got
clean often and you know he absorbed
most of it I believe in the final few
punches that he kind of turned away and
the ref stopped that I think the ref
knew something was wrong with Tony and
obviously there was so great stoppage
his orbital was broken if they would
have continued to fight you know the
broken orbital could cause you to go
blind and a lot of bad things can happen
if you could hit while you're you know
structure your face is broken so great
job by the ref and but but I was really
surprised at Tony's durability man I
didn't I didn't think he was that
durable um would you have stopped that
uh would you have stopped the crews -
whoo - a fight that's tough because I
thought Cruz was you know building uh I
thought he was starting to and there was
only a few seconds left in the round
yeah and it's a world title fight you
know man of course on this side is a
fighter
I want to let me go out you know I know
what I signed up for I know what I'm
walking in there to do I know the
dangers yeah let me go out all the way
so we know the fights over
and I feel like Cruz was kind of robbed
of that opportunity to be put all the
way out and or to get up and continue
fighting yeah you gotta let it play out
you gotta let it play out um UFC in
boxing world obviously you know cross
paths sometimes have you have you heard
anything about a Tyson come back I heard
some rumblings of him maybe join a
bare-knuckle fighting and AM yeah bro
that's brutal I've been to a few of
their shows up into one I'm here in
Miami and I've been to one in
Mississippi and dude that's hard to
watch man and I love fights and I've
been to thousands of fights sitting
ringside and watching these guys bump
knuckles it's does it take you back to
all does it take you back to a time like
in the beginning of your career or it is
it just a totally different ballgame
yeah it's a it's a you know I've never
fought bare-knuckle only in street
fights you know but I've never fought a
sanctioned bare-knuckle fight only at
Mardi Gras oh dude that's why don't we
go to Mardi Gras yeah in Louisiana right
yeah you too many guys won uh too many
fake Mike Perry's want to show up you
know yeah yeah I don't want them
problems
I don't know but I know they are
bare-knuckle also fight assigned to
former world champion Shannon Briggs a
guy out here in Florida so if Tyson does
sign the toe bare-knuckle I mean these
are two legitimate heavyweight champions
of the world that could fight
bare-knuckle would be it would be
madness Wow that'd be crazy to see Tyson
bare-knuckle dude he's 50 something
years old Oh yup it looks like right the
way he's moving oh man each one of his
knuckles is like a fist they say yeah
powers the last thing to go real aging
as a fighter yet powers the last thing
to go damn and that's what he had the
most of all power yeah
well cool may have best of luck dude I
hope you have a good time over there
with your family in Florida man and
excited to see you in the ring man
hopefully as soon as a month yeah they
said next month so somebody's gang man
Dustin the diamond 48 thanks so much
champ we'll see you soon yes sir thank
you all right cheers brother
and that is Dustin Poirier right there
and and sports are back man it did feel
good to have sports being back it felt
good to I mean I can't I don't know what
the numbers were how many people tuned
in to that
but just to have people just to see
people doing something interacting and
to see people fighting in real life not
on Facebook was nice they should have
one round it's just too [ __ ]
Facebook put them out there huh put them
little dirty bears out there in the park
and see them but no always a pleasure to
talk to - Dustin excited to see the next
step of his career
you know just exciting man to be in that
world you know just to be in that world
where just the fierceness of it and so
just to get in and want to get into a
fight and imagine being in a fight and
knowing what you're doing in the fight
that was always the hardest thing for me
but I would get in a fight didn't have
no clue who I was doing I was not I just
felt like I was
not fighting that's what I felt like I
was doing a lot of times but no people
want to get back to regular life but is
regular life ever gonna be the same it's
a little risky you know it's wild man
it's a it's you know there's it's a
rebirth it's a rebirth going on which is
just so fitting that Mother's Day just
passed because it's a rebirth you know
and what are we gonna do I like the way
that Dustin doesn't many show up you
fight we keep fighting we keep fighting
man that's what we do what else I think
we did well for today you know this past
card was the first card of UFC that I
watched all the way through from top to
bottom man it was great and you know
Dustin brought up Bryce Mitchell and he
did a great job you know he were you
know really fortunate that he and Dustin
and Urijah Faber have been our only UFC
guests to come in and and we've wanted
to have some more and maybe we will in
the future but you know I'm just I've
been learning about the sport but just
you know a lot of people are just
itching to go whatever their job is if
they's a fighter they ready to fight if
they's a milkman ain't ready to drop off
that milk you know they're ready to drip
that leche on their neighbor or on
somebody
splash somebody with a little bit of
that white [ __ ] breast gunpowder
you know everybody's ready to kind of
get back and fight
I think we got I think we got to a good
space here I think I've we got to a good
space you know these are our lives man
these are our lives these are our lives
and we got to live them you know we got
to live them so if you're struggling
with some motivation I you know I really
hope that you find it in and just take
that next step take a small step in a
few small steps make a big step and a
few big steps make a real distance and
you can be in a new space thank you guys
for being here and being a part of my
life today and uh and you guys be good
oh I got the hiccups man I don't even
have anything add some water oh my god
well I'm not gonna waste your time or my
time anymore
not really my time this is the really
the most exciting thing that I do uh
what else that's it man we did it we did
it you know I'm thankful to everybody
that gave in a call think you too
producer Nick for making this episode
you know making this happen today think
you too Dustin Poirier for for uh for
jumping on a call with us and and
gracing us with his presence to talk
about fighting you know he has a good
speaking of fighting he has a charity
called the good fight foundation and
we'll put the Lincoln in the YouTube
here and and thank all you guys for for
continuing to fight man this is our
lives you know and we all have different
ways that we go about fighting but
but we don't give up you gotta be good
to your salesmen
and I'm gonna do the same for me man we
deserve it brother gang I'm just sitting
on your front porch wondering how could
I be so far from my home and my mind is
somewhere else but when I found it our
patch up where it's been grown now I'm
just floating on the breeze and I
[Music]
thought it's gonna take
a little time for me to set that parking
brake
Oh
[Music]
moving way too fast on the runaway train
with an 11
[Music]
and these whales that are better I've
known their walk so this template damn
[Music]
to make sense of world I came
Oh
[Music]
if you call my name
[Applause]
[Music]